So today we're going to take the plunge
and do the actual outbreak of warfare.
However, now that I've
teased you that way, um,
I do actually want us to
get to declare independence.
If you think about it.
We didn't quite get there yesterday,
so I do want us to declare independence,
um, for, for just a few minutes.
We're going to close that off and
then we will move on to the opening of
hostilities and the logic behind
them and really what they show.
So thinking back to Tuesday,
Tuesday,
we ended with a discussion of the,
the editing of the completed
draft of the declaration.
And I mentioned the Jeffersons.
Passage on slavery was cut out of the
final document for any number of reasons.
One of them obviously
being that for southerners,
that would have been a deal breaker.
And also because there were all sorts
of inherent in consistencies in what
Jefferson had written.
Now the editing process went on for a
few days only it wasn't longer than that.
These is actually events are unfolding
pretty quickly here as far as drafting,
editing, passing, and moving on with
the declaration of independence. Um,
and Jefferson did not enjoy the
editing process. Do you ever send,
hated the editing process because he
really thought they were completely
mangling his beautiful,
wonderful prose.
So supposedly he sat in the corner of
the room in the main chamber of the
congress looking really miserable.
Okay.
Just sort of cringing and wincing
every time they cut another one who was
beautiful words or substituted
some other word in there.
So apparently, and we get this
partly from Jefferson himself,
he looked so miserable that Benjamin
Franklin ended up going over to him to try
to cheer him up.
And I'm,
I'm offering this partly because I'm
always trying obviously to get us past the
sort of Ah, like American
revolution. The declaration, right?
I'm trying to sort of make this human
right. Human documents, human moments,
human struggling.
So we're now really going to humanize
the declaration of independence.
So Jefferson says he's sitting there,
where are his words here? Okay.
He said Franklin quote perceived that I
was not insensible to these mutilations.
Okay.
So Franklin saw that according
to Jefferson and how much
I hated the mutilating
my document.
And Franklin ends up telling Jefferson
a story and then Jefferson kindly for us
looking on preserve the story so I can
offer you the story that Franklin told
Jefferson basically to distract him while
they were editing the declaration of
independence.
So Franklin told this story of a header
named John Thompson and this pattern
named John Thompson wanted to open a shop
and he wanted to create a sign to hang
over the door and he
planned on having the sign,
say John Thompson header makes
and sells hats for ready money.
And then there'd be a picture of a hat.
So that's his plan.
But he decides he'll run the signed by
a few of his friends to see what they
think. Is that the right sign for him
to put up in front of his new shop?
So he goes to one friend
and the first friend says,
well you don't really need
the word had or do you?
Because obviously if you make
and sell hats, you're a header.
So you can just cut the word header.
The next one says makes you really
have to say makes hats mean.
Obviously their hats, you don't
need, the word makes, you can cut.
The word makes it's unneeded on the sign.
Another says, why say for ready money,
like what you're going to give away, the
hats, like you can cut for ready money.
And so obviously this goes on and on.
Franklin continues to tell this anecdote
until in the end the sign just is John
Thompson and has a picture of a hat.
Okay,
so Franklin gels with story and
then he says the moral of the story,
he even had a moral,
the moral of the story is that Franklin
made it tried quote whenever in my power
to avoid becoming the draftsmen of
papers to be reviewed by a public body.
Okay?
Never write anything that a public buddy,
we'll edit because you will be very sad
and all of your words will be sliced
away.
So that's this little tiny human moment
happening in the corner of the chamber
or the Continental Congress is meeting.
Meanwhile,
they're editing the document on July
2nd [inaudible] 1776 congress votes for
independence two days later on July
4th after all of the editing and
Jeffersonian cringing,
Congress formally adopted the
Declaration of independence.
So we have declared independence. We've
adopted the declaration of independence,
but obviously now something has to happen
to the document and it wasn't intended
to be something that was sort of filed
away. It was intended, obviously,
to have an impact. And there were two
audiences in mind. On the one hand,
people in the Congress did think that if
they declared their intentions and what
they were doing in some
sort of a document,
that the outer world people
beyond the colonies, first of all,
would understand what was going on and
then hopefully might even want to offer
aid, right? Any, basically, if they're
declaring independence against Britain,
maybe people who don't like
Britain will want to help us.
So first they're thinking
possibly a European audience,
but even more important than that, they're
thinking about a domestic audience.
They're thinking about having
the American people under,
not only understand what's happening,
but really here this document that
they've tinkered every word over the
congresses, feelings about
what they think is happening,
what they believe is
going on in the colonies,
what they are declaring to the world.
And so what happens basically is once
the document is past, it's issued,
the congress sent it out to any number of,
they sent it out to the continental army
many copies so that it could be read to
people in the army.
And the continental army comes Tuesdays,
I don't think I forgot the continental
army and George Washington comes Tuesday.
Um, they sent it out to
um, state assemblies.
They sent it out to committees of safety.
Basically they found it any number of
avenues to send out this document so that
it could be read aloud.
And that was the plan wasn't for people
to sort of read this interestingly in
their newspaper,
but they actually had public
readings of it on courthouse steps,
um, in public squares at
public meetings, town meetings.
It was sort of a performed document.
It was being read so people
could hear what independence,
how independence was being declared.
And in response there were all kinds of
public celebrations and demonstrations.
So there were fireworks,
there were parades and there was a lot
of symbolic destruction of some of the
trappings of the crown.
So basically images of the king,
like on a tavern sign were ripped down.
We're broken into pieces were
burned in bonfires in New York City.
This famous image of this
that you may have seen,
they pulled down a large statue
of the king mounted on his horse.
They actually literally pulled it down
and then later headed melted into bullets
for the war effort. So clearly,
boy, isn't that a slap you,
I heard a noise over there. That's
true. It's like King George.
Not only did we tear you down,
but we're going to use you to
shoot at you with your own statue.
So obviously independence is a moment,
does an event,
it's not just a document. So,
and I should note here too,
that now that independence is declared
what had been colonies are not colonies
any longer, right? It feel
like declared independence.
And they're saying they are no
longer colonies of Great Britain.
I'm going to try to remember from here
on out to begin to use the word state.
They're frantically,
and I'll talk more about this on Tuesday,
they're frantically now also worrying
about state constitutions to replace where
the royal government government
had been in the past,
but now obviously we're
not colonies anymore.
We're moving on to another sort of state
of being and in their mind actually
even another word,
but of course there's that
obvious looming question at hand,
right? Warfare, conflict, hostility.
Something is looming and there's no
clear path as to how whatever's going to
happen next is going to unfold or how
it should be played out or even just how
these newly declared states
are going to execute warfare.
How should they organize the effort?
How should this war be fought?
How might it possibly be one?
Right?
The idea of winning a war against the
power at the might of the British army to
say the least, that would have been
really daunting to these people.
The odds would have felt seemingly
impossible. And then on top of that,
what about organizing whatever
effort you were going to take.
What about organizing?
How were you supposed to do that?
Particularly given that the continental
Congress says we'll discuss next week,
didn't have any absolute power to
really enforce much of what it did.
Medic making it as we'll see even more
difficult for them to sort of organize
and carry out a war effort.
So basically today and Tuesday I'm
going to be talking about the process of
opening a war and organizing a war.
Um,
basically in the process showing
something about the mindset on both sides.
And today particularly,
you're going to get a sense
just by looking on ground
level at what's happening
between British soldiers.
And I'm going to feel say
colonist cause it's in my head.
We'll move on to Americans, but I'm
going to, colonist is right here.
I can't vanish it yet. I'm feeling
very colonial. Like it's my habit,
my British tradition. Um, at any rate, um,
today you're going to get a sense of
the real mindset of the different sides
because you're going to
see people interacting.
And I have a number of different sort of
eyewitness accounts of different events.
So you can get a sense of the logic behind
what people are thinking is going on
as some of these hostilities unfold.
So today we're going to be looking
at conflict in the last two lectures.
We clearly in one way or another
had been leading up to this moment.
So we talked about common sense, talked
about the declaration of independence.
And in discussing both of those documents,
I've made several references
to the surrounding mood.
And I think I've used several times
that any of the colonies were on fire.
It was pain's a version of what pain
said that the colony seemed to be on fire
in 1775 and that's what
inspires him to want to write.
So what we're going to do is basically
look and see what that means.
What is pain referring to,
what is happening in 1775 that pushed
him to feel so compelled to write.
So we're going to look at the physical
aspect of events unfolding mostly in 1775
a little bit in 1776 the physical reality
of the onset of actual hostilities,
what,
what the colonial hostility to the
British soldiers stationed in the colonies
felt like how that was unfolding,
what the British soldiers were doing,
how they thought they were going to
stem the tide of whatever was happening.
But as I've already said in any number
of times in this course, even now,
we're on the cusp of some
kind of physical clash.
We're not looking at two competing groups
of people who see themselves as being
entirely distinct and separate peoples.
And we certainly seen on both sides a
sort of gradual realization that maybe the
logic of governance is
different on both sides.
The logic or the understanding of the
empire is different on both sides of the
Atlantic.
But we don't have two people here who
see themselves as enemies societies as
Lord Rockingham put it in
parliament speaking at the time.
He feared that they were looking at quote,
the dreadful calamity of shedding
British blood by British hands.
So what we're talking
about here is civil war.
That's why I titled This Lecture
Civil War, because that's what it was.
It was a people divided.
There are actually people in at the time,
certainly I can think of some in the 1790s
who call the revolution the civil war.
That's what it was.
That's what it felt like.
That really sort of drives that home.
Now,
the first battles of this war are fought
in 1775 but they don't represent a sort
of sudden plunging into the inevitability
of war and it's actually quite the
opposite. You'll see that as
these events unfold today,
both sides to some degree really see
themselves as behaving defensively and
ultimately they point the finger at the
other side, but in one way or another,
both sides feel that they're trying to
sort of prevent bad things from happening.
Now on the colonial side,
people assumed that they
were collecting arms,
that they were creating
local militia units,
that they were beginning
to stockpile weapons,
that this was all a defensive measure.
And at the end of the
first continental congress,
they actually had declared that maybe the
colonies should think about organizing
themselves for defensive
measures. So there had been,
again, not a sort of a Jack,
a Jack measure from the
first continental congress,
but maybe it's time that we actually
should really begin organizing. But again,
this is,
this is seen as a defensive measure.
That same kind of spirit of defensive
protection still infuses the second
continental congress.
And I mentioned in the last lecture the
two things that are happening at the
same time.
So the congress is trying to figure
out what to do about a possible war and
sending out the olive branch
petition at the same time.
Both of those things are
happening at the same time,
so they're not jumping into a war,
they're preparing defensive
measures on the British side.
The general assumption was
that a few strategic moves,
a couple of really grand
military maneuvers and maybe
one big display of power
and the whole thing would collapse.
That there's no way the
colonists could not be dumb,
struck an odd by the
force of the British army,
so whatever it was going to happen,
there'd be one little clash and it would
be over and if they could just sees the
weapons and the ammunition and the
things that were being stockpiled,
they could sort of cut things
off before it even got any worse.
They could just collect the weapons
and take them away and that the power,
the ease with which they would have
marched at this point into New England and
seized arms and weapons would show the
colonists that this wasn't worth fighting.
It's not a fight worth fighting.
It's not a fight that they could fight.
So by trying to collect weapons,
trying to collect ammunition,
they're trying to stem again,
it's defensive.
They're trying to stop things
from getting worse. Now.
There were a few reasons why the British
would have assumed one little gesture,
and it's over. Now, obviously
the most obvious one is
just the British army. Okay?
We're talking to you about the British
army and a bunch of colonists who just
went out and decided maybe
we'd better drill now. Okay.
So certainly to the British, what
their thinking is, well, please,
you know that against us.
Okay,
we don't even have to worry about that.
But more than that,
the British also thought,
generally speaking,
that the colonists were a lot of
bluster and little more that they just,
they had, they had a lot of hot
air, they're in the colonies,
but that there actually
wasn't a lot more to them.
Certainly not a lot of bravery. And the
word cowards is tossed around a lot.
And in letters and writings and even in
speeches in parliament from this time
period. So as an example, in the
House of Lords, someone apparently,
um, stands up and says, you know,
there are a lot of men in the colonies
who could fight against us if they chose
to fight the colonies abound in
men who could serve as soldiers.
So the Earl of sandwich stands
up and this is his response.
Suppose the colonies do a bound in men.
What does that signify?
They are raw, undisciplined, cowardly men.
I wish instead of 50 or
50,000 of these brave fellows,
they would produce in the field at least
200,000. The more the better. Okay?
That's,
that's a really good arrogant British
guy in the world of arrogant British
comyns. Believe me, my Lord,
the very sound of a canon would carry
them off as fast as their feet could carry
them. This is two trifling a part of the
argument to detain your Lordship's any
longer. Okay, please. We're not
talking about a real threat,
nor were the British very
impressed at the idea.
That's the whole idea of
colonial civilians dressed
up suddenly in military garb
and suddenly positioning
themselves as soldiers.
So one English visitor to the colonies
wrote a letter to a friend in England and
express the same feeling.
He said,
it is a curious masquerade scene
to see graves, sober citizens,
barbers and tailors who never
looked fierce before in their lives,
but their wives,
children or apprentices.
He's always like the little backhanded
guys shoes that they totally,
it goes into these quotes so they've only
looked fierce before it. Their wives,
children are apprentices strutting
about in their Sunday wigs,
in stiff buckles with their
muskets on their shoulders.
Struggling to put on a
Marshall countenance.
If ever you saw a goose
assume an air of consequence,
you may catch some faint idea of the
foolish awkward puffed up stair of our
tradesmen.
The wig indeed is the most frightful thing
about them for it's very hairs seemed
to bristle up in defiance of
the sh the soldiers. Okay,
that's a wonderful little passage about
exactly what some people thought it
looked like they were
doing in the colonies.
General gauge commanding the British
forces in America felt similarly.
That basically one big display of force
and they could close things off and you
can hear this as well as his impatience
with this sort of ongoing colonial
hostility to the troops that were
positioned in the colonies in some threats
that he made to some Boston radicals that
he met with in 1775 so according to an
account, he, he quote,
swore to it by the living God that if
there was a single man of the kings troops
killed in any of their towns
and the nanny of the your towns,
your Massachusetts downs,
he would burn it to the ground.
What fools you are to pretend to resist
the power of Great Britain. Okay?
That to me is like Darth Vader,
what fools you are. I was like, wow,
that's a statement of power. How dare
you hold yourselves against the empire,
the empire.
She maintained the last war 300,000 men
and we'll do the same now rather than
suffer the ungrateful people of this
country to continue in their rebellion.
Okay.
It's clear how gage fields,
so the colleges are preparing
to defend themselves.
The British and gauge are
assuming a little display,
a forceful and the manner neither side
is assuming there's a pending war and you
can see both of these views and play at
a little event. It's not a big moment.
It's actually prior to Lexington
and Concord that plays out also in
Massachusetts in February of 1775 on
February 26 gauge decided that he would
have some troops moved to Salem,
Massachusetts to seize cannons and guns
that the colonists had collected there.
So this is part of that strategy.
Well let's just take the weapons away
and we'll march and we'll look impressive
and they will be nervous and
this will be good on all counts.
And I'm going to read from an account
of someone who was there actually,
who describes what he saw and
what happened on Sunday 26,
February, 1775 my father came home
from church rather sooner than usual,
which attracted my notice
and said to my mother,
the regulars are come and our marching
as fast as they can towards the north
fields bridge and looking towards
her with a very solemn face remarked,
I don't know what will be the consequence,
but something very serious and I wish
you to keep the children home. Okay,
so you've got a sense of, Huh? There's
like soldiers marching now towards us.
What does this mean?
I looked out of the window just at this
time and saw the troops passing the
house and apparently they were playing
Yankee doodle just to be insulting.
Um,
Colonel David Mason had received tidings
of the approach of the British troops
and ran into the North Church during
service and cried out at the top of his
voice. The regulars are coming
for the guns. At this point.
Several men ran out to move the
guns and the account continues.
My father looked in between the platoons
to see if he could recognize any of the
soldiers who had been stationed
at Fort William on the neck,
many of whom were known to him.
And that's always an
interesting little detail to me,
be soldiers had been there long enough
that there's just been mingling of
soldiers and people.
And so here are the troops are marching
and this person's father was sort of
going into the crowd to see
if there's someone here.
I know I could ask him what's happening
where, why are they coming here?
What are their plans?
But he could discover,
know familiar faces was black guarded
by the soldiers for his inquisitiveness.
Who asked him with odes what he was
looking at. You can actually hear that.
What are you looking at? Like
get out of the way. Okay,
so at this point there's a group of
colonists who see the advancing troops.
They go to this bridge that clearly the
British want to get to in March across
to get to the guns and the colonists
pull up a drawbridge so that the soldiers
can't go any further.
And now we get this sort of great
and somewhat bizarre standoff.
The British commander is standing on
one side and they were calling us on the
other side of the drawbridge is up and
the British commander said that his
troops would fire if the
colonists don't lower the bridge.
The local militia captain says,
well if you fire then you're
all going to be dead men.
And supposedly the plan of the
militia captain was if anyone fired,
he was going to run at the head of the
British troops and kill him and then
throw himself in the
river and drowned himself.
So he didn't get punished for killing
a British soldier. But he was like,
he had his plan, he was ready to
act. Okay. It's like a good plan.
Um, okay. So at this point soldiers,
civilians are eye witnesses.
It was that,
it was a cold day and he noticed that
these soldiers aren't wearing coats and
that actually they're beginning to look
really miserable and they're starting to
shiver cause they're just standing
there in front of the bridge,
unable to go anywhere.
And meanwhile,
some colonists climbed out on the other
side of the bridge and they're taunting
the soldiers and apparently one
particularly loud person yelled out,
soldiers, red jackets,
lobster coats, cowards,
damnation to your government and everybody
else shut them up because they really
didn't want to be fired upon.
Right?
It's one thing to just
like sit there and mumble.
It's another to say damnation to your
government and taunt the abrasion to
shooting.
At this point,
the British commander said that he would
get over the bridge if he had to stay
there until autumn. Right? He says,
by God, I will not be defeated.
To which the colonial captain
basically replies and said, yeah, well,
I think you already have been defeated
because you're here and the weapons are
there and I don't see you moving.
The British commander insisted
that this was the king's highway,
old Mr. James Bar, an Englishman and a
man of much nerve then replied to him,
it is not the king's highway.
It is a road built buddy owners
of the lots on the other side,
and no king country or town has anything
to do with it. Okay. King's highway,
my foot. So now the British
commander is stuck, right?
He doesn't want to lose face. He's not
going to surrender to these colonials.
He wants to do something. So this to me
is the most amazing part of the story.
He actually proposes to the militia
captain that if he and his men are allowed
to cross the bridge,
he promises that they will march
50 feet turn around and March back.
Right. It's like I won.
I got across the bridge.
They're not going to go after the weapons.
It's just a symbolic victory.
Like they got what they wanted,
the colonials back down,
we'll just march 50 feet,
we'll turn around and then march
away and that's exactly what happens.
They let them cross. They march,
they turn around and they march away.
Apparently with the troops marching to
the song, the world turned upside down.
We see. We're going to see that again in
the when there's an actual war, but okay.
Little symbolic.
Okay,
well maybe I didn't entirely lose
face kind of moment by the British.
So there you can see pretty literally
the British assuming that a little
marching, a few threats,
everything will fold. They'll
seize weapons, end of matter.
That didn't happen here.
You can see in the colonist sort
of standing there defensively,
not wanting to cause trouble,
but also not turning around and running.
They're defending.
Now at roughly this same
point back in England,
even as some members of parliament were
sneering at the idea of these sort of
fighting colonials and as soldiers were
trying to stave off trouble by seizing
weapons and ammunitions,
others in parliament,
we're actually thinking of trying to
extensive conciliatory gestures and maybe
that would actually end this
before it became a lot worse.
And in particular in the House of Lords,
William Pitt made a number of
proposals trying to smooth things over.
All of them were rejected.
So he proposes that perhaps they
actually couldn't recognize colonial self
government. Okay. That didn't go very
far. Surprise. Um, eat said, okay,
well what about withdrawing British
troops from Boston? Rejected.
Instead in February, 1775 new England
is declared to be in rebellion,
but now we have one last
stab at reconciliation on
the part of the British Lord
North,
and I'm mentioning this here because I've
already talked about the olive branch
petition. In a way, this is the
equivalent on the other side of the ocean.
What we were going to see
here is one attempt to extend,
one more offer that maybe maybe at
this last second will stave things off.
People are trying to find a way out of
the problem and really struggling to find
some kind of mutual ground.
So Lord North passes a resolution.
It's ultimately called the conciliatory
resolution and it proposed that any
colony that contributed to the common
defense and supported the civil government
and the administration of justice would
be relieved of paying taxes or duties
except as needed to regulate commerce.
I'll repeat that.
The conciliatory resolution and February
17th 75 it proposes that any colony
that contributes to the common defense
and supports the civil government and the
administration of justice
would be relieved of paying
taxes or duties except as
needed to regulate commerce.
Many in parliament were somewhat
stunned by this gesture.
Even though obviously parliament
is not giving up any of its rights.
It's just making a nice offer,
but it's not saying we
don't have the power to tax.
We're just saying we won't tax.
But many in parliament were stunned.
There's one observer said,
uncertainty, surprise, distraction.
We're seated on every countenance.
When this plan came forth to some the
seem to be backing down to others that
seem beside the point that basically
what the colonies needed was firmness and
these kinds of concessions.
We weren't really going to do anything
but the resolution goes forward.
North sends it on to the colonies.
He very deliberately did not send it to
the continental congress which he didn't
recognize,
but instead he sent it to individual
colonial assemblies thinking that if some
of them, even just the
handful of individual colonial
assemblies agreed to this,
then the colonies would be divided and
this is an example of something we're
going to see again and again and again
in a variety of ways in the process of
fighting the war.
It's a really common assumption on the
part of the British that all they need to
do is just divide the colonies and that
there are any number of ways in which it
will be really easy to just
sort of ruin their loyalties,
turn them against each other and then
this whole thing can be brought to a close
and what we'll see is what they're
underestimating. On the one hand it's,
I've already talked about in lectures,
we've seen how hard it is for the
colonies to do anything jointly,
but we've also seen if
there's an outside threat,
they actually come together relatively
effectively for short period of time.
So at the British are underestimating
here is that actually there is some unity.
There is a sense of United cause
because of an outside threat.
So north pass is the resolution.
Um,
obviously it did not go far enough at
this point for the colonial leaders.
It's still maintained the
right of parliament to
basically do what it wanted to
do with taxes.
But also in addition to not being enough
of a gesture towards reconciliation,
the timing was really poor because it
didn't reach the colonies until after the
outbreak of fighting at
Lexington and Concord. Now,
given what I described at Salem,
you can see the continued logic of what
the British troops were attempting to do
at Lexington and Concord. Basically,
they want to seize powder.
They want to see his arms, they want to
get the weapons, they're gonna March.
They're going to have
an impressive display,
grabbed the stuff and leave
and make a big impact.
Americans were very closely
watching the troops by this time.
They knew as soon as the troops
set out that they were marching,
even though the troops,
apparently we're trying to be somewhat
secretive about what they were doing.
And here we have the famous Paul Revere
moment and the Poor William Dawes,
the poor neglected Willie's cause
like me too. He was there too.
He was riding along both of them. Paul
Revere and William Dawes, uh, writing,
basically telling people that the
British regulars are on the move.
They're on the march.
Meanwhile the British are marching
towards Lexington on their way to Concord,
which is where the arms are and they're
beginning to become nervous because
before they get to towns they can
hear the church bells ringing.
So basically some things going on in that
town and we haven't gotten there yet.
So somehow or other,
they know we're coming.
One soldier later described how a quote,
very genteel man in a carriage stopped
and told them that there were 600 armed
men waiting for them on Lexington
common. Okay. As we'll see,
there were not 600 are men.
There were maybe roughly 70 men who
heard the church bell knew that was a bad
thing, grabbed their weapons and went to
Lexington, common in her sort of steady,
they're okay.
Not 600 the British entered Lexington
at about four o'clock in the morning.
They saw this group of about
70 people on Lexington.
Common supposedly yelled rebels,
disperse America's later claim that what
they said was you damn rebels lay down
your arms.
So Americans always hear the,
if there is a sliver of the Americans
here at at which point a gun was fired and
it's unclear who fired the gun.
But when that gun was fired,
the British opened fire. There were
a few American shots and return.
The American commander told his men
quote to take care of themselves,
which means run if you want.
And so they did leaving behind eight dead,
roughly eight dead and 10 wounded.
And now the British continue
on pushing onto Concord,
which is why they came there in the first
place to get the powder that's being
stored there. And they actually
met more militia men on the way.
And when they marched on them,
these people actually fled,
which is in a sense what
they really expecting.
The British began to destroy
these colonial stores,
the ammunition and the weapons.
Meanwhile,
the colonist collected near the North
Bridge to stop the British and a few
British shots were fired. Americans fired
a few shots back before they withdrew.
Again,
it's only a temporary retreat,
so the Americans keep doing something
and then fleeing and then coming back and
then fleeing.
It's a temporary retreat on the parts
of the colonist because as a British
officer later reported as they left
Concord after they destroyed these
ammunitions quote,
we were fired on from houses and behind
trees and before we had gone a half mile,
we were fired on from all sides,
but mostly from the rear where people
had hid themselves in houses until we had
passed and then fired.
The country was an amazing,
strong one full of hills,
woods, stone walls,
which the rebels did not fail to
take advantage of in this way.
We marched between nine and 10 miles.
Their numbers increasing from all
parts while ours was reduced by deaths,
wounds,
and fatigued.
And another officer later recalled that
he heard colonist and actually even saw
some of them standing in the road
yelling out king Hancock forever. Okay.
Where that came from,
I can't tell you,
but they're out there sort of
declaring their political cause.
This is hardly what the British expected.
And for that matter, in a sense,
the colonist didn't expect
that sort of event to unfold.
But this level of colonial resistance
to the British was a surprise as another
British soldier put it.
The enthusiastic zeal with which these
people have behaved must convince every
reasonable man what a difficult and
unpleasant task general gauge has before
him.
Even women had fire locks.
British response on the one hand is,
oh, okay. They didn't just melt away.
This will be unpleasant for general gauge.
All told roughly 250 British
soldiers were killed.
Roughly 95 Americans for the British.
Obviously this suggests that
little display of military might,
might not be enough for the colonists.
It revealed the existence of an
honest to goodness, physical threat.
As John Adams put it,
Lexington was proof that quote,
if we did not defend ourselves,
they would kill us.
I don't always just states it.
Okay.
Almost immediately,
people from both sides began
to use the clash as propaganda,
basically playing it up so
that they seem defensive.
And the other side seems as
though it's the aggressor.
So colonists sent writers out to tell
people in other towns and other colonies
about how the British had killed
every person they came across.
Women and children, they driven
pregnant women into the street.
They shot dead old men. You know, it's
like anything we can think of. They did.
So obviously they're exaggerating a bit
what happened in Lexington and Concord,
but British accounts
were no less creative.
The British accused Americans
of scalping dead and dying.
British soldiers claiming quote,
they were full,
as bad as the Indians for scalping and
cutting the dead man's ears and noses off
and those they get alive that are wounded
and can't get off the ground. Okay?
They're scalping live men. Those colonists
is what the British are charging.
They claim that the
Americans had fired first,
that Americans didn't fight fair
because they were hiding that they were
cowardly because they were lying on
their bellies hiding instead of standing
upright, which is how a traditional
army was supposed to fight.
But both sides clearly are positioning
themselves as being defensive.
At this point in June,
June of 1775,
the English got more evidence that the
Americans weren't just going to run when
colonists attempted to station themselves
on breed's hill in overlooking Boston,
not bunker hill actually, but retail, um,
and the Americans were thinking, well,
this will be very strategic if
we go to the top of this hill.
It overlooks Boston.
It's a good place for us to have power
and control over the British see that as
well. And they attack to
prevent the colonists from
taking control of that hill.
That conflict is later called
the battle of Bunker Hill.
It should be the battle of breed's hill,
but although the British ultimately
did claim the hill and could claim a
victory,
it was a pretty expensive victory.
They lost roughly 1000 out of 2000 men.
They had enormous casualties.
The Americans lost roughly 400 men,
so the British really suffered a
lot of losses and at this point,
gauge learned a lesson as he observed.
After seeing all of these clashes,
the colonists were quote,
not the despicable rabble, too
many of suppose them to be, wow,
there are less of a despicable
rebel than I thought they were.
These people show a spirit
and conduct against us.
They never showed against the French,
which I also think is interesting.
What he's saying is,
well,
we thought we knew these people from that
French and Indian war and they weren't
too impressive then, but they're
actually behaving differently now.
Everybody has judged of them from
their former appearance and behavior.
When joined with the king's
forces in the last war,
which has led many integrate mistakes,
they are now spirited up
by a rage and enthusiasm.
As great as people were possessed
of colonists also learned a lesson,
and you can see this most dramatically
in New York state, New York.
At the time,
there were a number of conservatives and
loyalists who were in power in New York.
It wasn't a radical colony.
Um,
they had actually sent more conservative
delegates to the first continental
congress.
There had even been talk in New York
about not sending delegates to the second
continental congress because good men
got corrupted when they went to hang out
with those scary radical guys
in the continental congress.
And basically the crown saw New York as
a good thing because they were sort of
more loyal than many
of the other colonies.
That's New York before the
events I've talked about today,
after these events,
New York made something of a turnaround.
They hanged Lord North in effigy,
they seem seized arms belonging to the
city and distributed them to citizens.
And ultimately the British marched out
of New York City and retreated to a ship
in the harbor with the colonist grabbing
at their baggage and their ammunition
as they left.
So that obviously shows that there
is an impact all over the colonies.
People began to feel the need to prepare
for war as one colon his throat in July
of 1775 travel through whatever
part of this country you will,
you see the inhabitance training,
making fire locks, casting mortars,
shells and shot and making salt.
Peter Philadelphia was decorated with
flags announcing liberty or death.
People are really now
motivated with a real,
I guess rage and enthusiasm is a good
way of putting it at these recent events.
So now you can,
you truly do get a sense of
how the colonies were indeed
set on fire in 1775 you
can see what it is that
pain was responding to.
You can see why in January of 1776
when common sense was published,
why it had the impact it did because
people were ready to hear its message.
They were willing to at least begin to
consider independence because of what was
unfolding in 1775 things.
We're at a difficult point at this point
and if you step back and just look at
the larger logic of what's going on,
you can really see how difficult it would
have been defined your way out of this
situation.
The British administration couldn't
really yield to demands of the continental
congress without sacrificing its
sovereignty over the colonies.
And I suppose in their eyes
also humiliating itself
before the eyes of the world
along similar lines.
The con is couldn't really back down
about their demands without seeming to
surrender what they consider to be
some of their fundamental rights.
And they suspected British attempts
at conciliation anyway because they,
every time the British made any sort of
gesture that seemed to be moving in the
right direction, their thought was,
well, yeah, they're trying to appease us.
So we stopped protesting, but they're just
going to be tyrants underneath it all.
There's,
there's,
they're basically trying to make us
quiet so they can impose Tierney upon us.
But I do want to point out, and I've just
described all of these dramatic events,
men being killed, battles,
people rate, storing arms,
a lot of drama.
But I've talked about 1775
throughout this entire class, right.
And independence isn't declared
the roughly a year later.
Again,
which is a really dramatic way of
seeing that war is not inevitable,
that people are struggling to avoid it
even as they're doing all of this and
taking all of these actions and acting
in the moment at what's unfolding.
Even after Lexington and Concord,
in July of 1775 the continental congress
still sends out that olive branch
petition.
The American saw themselves as
Britain's as well as Americans.
They were defending their
rights as British subjects
and only over time did they
really gradually work their
way towards independence.
They had first assumed that there was
a small group of corrupt government
ministers who may be were leading things
the wrong way. Then they decided, well,
maybe it was parliament
that was the problem.
And only when the last prop
of the British constitution,
the monarch proved death to their cause.
Did colonist begin to feel
that independence might
be possible and ultimately
maybe it was going to be necessary.
Okay, so where does this leave us?
Well,
obviously it leaves us with a really
enormous looming challenge facing the
continental Congress,
right?
Think about the kind of El Congress
doesn't really have any power.
All these delegates in there and now poof,
they somehow have to help organize a
United war effort with no mechanism for
doing anything in a
United organized manner.
And I'm going to end the
lecture by letting John Adams
sum up this challenge at
this point,
what it felt like to be in the
continental congress at this scary point.
And he wrote this letter in 1775
to whose wife actually to Abigail.
And he wrote when 50 or 60 men have a
constitution to form for a great empire.
I liked the fact that it's a great
empire already. At the same time,
they have a country of 1500 miles extent
to fortify millions to arm and train a
naval power to begin an extensive
commerce to regulate numerous tribes of
Indians to negotiate with a Standing
Army of 27,000 men to raise pay.
Visceral and officer,
I shall really pity those 50 or 60 men.
Okay.
So that's Adam's saying, boy,
I'm not looking forward to this.
This is going to be an enormous task.
And what we're going to be looking
at Tuesday is that very thing.
How do you hold a war? How do you
begin to organize this kind of effort?
What were the things that
Congress immediately did?
George Washington is going to appear.
That's one of the things the continental
congress does at an early point,
is find,
try to create a continental army,
and Washington walks onto the
national scene at this point.
So we will look at the unfolding of the
war from a different angle. Next week.
I will stop there.